bonjour sébastien duval merci de
répondre à nos questions là donc appris
hier soir
lubrizol a une nouvelle fois mis en
examen mardi donc comment est ce que
vous avez réagi en apprenant cette
nouvelle votre association un des
sinistrés du brésil qui est partie
civile
bonjour m'écouter c'est pour nous c'est
une satisfaction parce qu'on en fait
c'est l'aboutissement de notre travail
on a travaillé depuis deux ans à faire
l'inventaire des substances avaient pu
brûler les 10000 tome 2 700 chimiques
ont pu brûler à l'affût lubrizol
est bien de données de sécurité de
l'industriel soit parfaitement
incomplète et que l'état se complaisent
a pas demandé le complément on sait
néanmoins qu'il ya entre eux 1100 et
2100 tonnes de produits nuisibles ou
boksic pour lui mieux aquatiques et les
poissons donc voilà ce travail
d'inventaire il a été versé au dossier
du juge et et on voit que ben il a pu
corroborer sa avec avec d'autres
éléments au point de d'ajouter une mise
en examen un industriel arrière beaucoup
de travail encore à faire on attend des
éclaircissements de l'état on sait aussi
que l'état pourrait être condamnée mec
l'étude de dangers qui permettrait de le
faire et dont on dispose en tant que
partie civile ne nous est pas mise à
disposition ce qui fait du coup on ne
peut pas porter civile porter plainte
avec cet élément dans un autre dossier
contre l'état pour ça c'est un manque
total de transparence on voit que l'état
depuis le début couvre l'industriel
autant qu'il peut bon c'est inadmissible
y encore beaucoup de choses à faire pour
protéger les populations en tout cas on
sait que ces produits chimiques
effectivement ils sont nocifs pour les
poissons mais pas que ça le brésil ou à
l'état
chirac c'est ça dure on fait affaire
depuis le début
lubrizol nous dit que les produits
hautement chimie qui font qu'ils sont
classés seveso qui ont pu brûler chez
eux c'est du petit lait et l'état vient
en appui à chaque occasion pour me dire
où va très bien madame la marquise et
pour preuve on a fait analyser la
dangerosité de la chose par l'industriel
lui même c'est n'importe quoi lubrizol
avait déjà dû s'acquitter en 2020 de
375000 euros de cautionnement est
constitué à une sûreté de 4 millions
d'euros qu'est-ce que vous attentez
qu'est ce que vous attendez cette fois
de la justice
on attend vraiment une peine exemplaire
parce qu'on s'aperçoit que en 2013 le
chef d'inculpation suite à la fille de
mercaptan ca et cc odeur d'oeuf pourri
qui avait cac avait été jusqu'à londres
le chef d'inculpation qui avait été
retenu et est si léger que finalement le
brise hall avait écopé d'une amende de
4000 euros amende si pau dissuasive que
finalement et mettez pas en oeuvre les
recommandations de sécurité lui
proposait même son assureur et avec les
conséquences qu'on a vu voilà ça c'est
quelque chose d'inadmissible nous ce
qu'on prononce également la création
d'un institut éco citoyen qui sera un
organisme indépendant de façon à
rassurer aussi les populations et à se
tenir prêt en cas de sinistre de cette
ampleur
justement dans quel état d'esprit se
trouve la population rouennaise
par rapport à ce qui s'est passé il ya
deux ans
et il ya en fait eu une défiance
importante vis-à-vis des autorités et de
la parole officielle
comme je vous le disais on nous tient un
discours qui est contraire à tout bon
sens vous avez des produits chimiques
transportés par des camions citernes
avec des logos qui vous met en alerte
sur le danger de leur contenu et à côté
quand ça brûle on vous dit ben non ça
craint rien n'importe qui qu'un peu de
bon sens comprend que on ne fait pas
preuve de transparence c'est quand qu'on
cache quelque chose
c'est bien un loup et en l'occurrence la
population on est toujours
dans cette expectative et dans cette
attente d'éclaircissements on a des
dirigeants lubrizol pour le moment est
ce que vous attendez des experts sysmans
également de l'entreprise qui est sous
contrôle du milliardaire américain
warren buffett depuis 2011
l'entreprise j'ai réservé diable depuis
deux ans on a perdu toute illusion sur
sa coopération on entend bien que ce
milliardaire s'il a fait fortune c'est
aussi parce que dans ces entreprises on
économise à chaque sou pour faire du
profit en est prêt à économiser sur
cette mesure de sécurité que le la
préfecture n'impose pas alors que la
norme l'exigent et les dérogations à
tout va que que permet la qui permet de
ça son complice en fait place à chaque
fois que l'état mais une norme mais
accorde à son préfet la possibilité de
faire de dérogation lorsqu'on trouve
avec des situations où voilà on a pas de
mur anti feu on n'a pas de bassins de
rétention et voilà ce que voilà ce que
ça donne merci sébastien du mal d'avoir
éperonné une question je rappelle que
vous êtes administrateur et cofondateur
de l'association des sinistrés de
lubrizol